hey everyone today i'm going to be
showing you how to get aeroshake for
windows
first thing you want to do in order to
get aeroshake which i'm sure you've
heard of it's a feature in windows 7
where you can grab a window so you have
multiple windows open calculator notepad
if you want to explore documents all you
do is shake it and they will disappear
now these aren't disappearing obviously
because i don't have
arrow shape so we're going to do to get
it is open your internet browser
and copy and paste the link in the
description or just click on it open it
in a new tab this link
take you directly to the site you're
going to take the direct download link
from lifehacker.com
and it will open up this it'll say
yes i want to open the aeroshake.exe
application
so it's already done downloading it's
only 200 kilobytes and i'm just going to
run it
and while it's opening i'm going to exit
out
of i'm going to leave these open
actually for the purpose of
demonstration
um of arrow shake so
we're waiting for the
uh installer to come up
actually we don't even have to wait for
the installer to come up it's already in
my system tray if i right click it i'm
sure we could find some more options for
it but now i'm going to try it out shake
this window
and it's the only window open wow that's
pretty cool
shake it again
all the rest of the windows come up
wow
so
obviously it's still in beta so it's not
going to be the most perfect
um if i had a larger screen capture area
i could show you this a lot more clearly
but as you can see i have quite a few
windows open and i will just shake it
they all disappear or minimize i'll
shake it again
and they will also my so it's great if
you want to focus on a window or to um
yeah just to get all your concentration
on one window such as a microsoft word
document to just uh shake the mic
software document and other they're all
minimized now you can always hit you
know windows d and then just open up
just the microsoft word
um there's plenty of other ways to do
this just maximize it or whatever but
that's just a cool windows 7 feature
that i thought that i would show you
guys
so um yeah that's basically it peace
you